- [Narrator] How would I describe the vibe
of Cascade on a Sunday night?
You would see 500, 800,
1,000 people in the facility.
You have this culture
that has been created,
and it's just growing out of control.
And you don't really experience that
anywhere else but here.
(upbeat music leading into choral singing)
- [Second Narrator]
When desegregation began
in the late '50s and early '60s,
some roller rink owners
did not take kindly to it.
They decided to create themed nights
specifically targeted
towards African-Americans.
If Black roller skaters made
an appearance on other days
of the week, they found
themselves unwelcome.
But those nights ended up turning
into something all of their own.
- I didn't realize the impact
that a roller skating
rink has on a community.
They would just open up a skating rink,
and, boy, people came,
and it was always crowded.
So all of those things came together
to really blow roller skating up.
Here is what so many people gravitate to.
And I didn't realize until
I actually built Cascade.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know where I would
be without roller skating.
It saved me.
So Sunday nights at Cascade
is amazing because of the energy.
We come, you got your crews, you got your
single skaters, you got your couples,
and it's time to show out.
It's the real Atlanta culture.
And you can kinda see the
style that Atlanta does.
We call it riding in Atlanta,
it's just a really cool, like,
you ride the beat and they go fast,
so we wear the low Carerra
skates with the big speed wheels,
and you see the guys doing the routines
and there are a couple of original groups
that still skate, and that
got the style started.
The roller skating culture is
like an underground family.
We have a Facebook, we have a skatebook.
It's kind of addictive,
it's our drug of choice,
and it's a nonstop party on wheels,
so that's kind of how
I fell in love with it.
- Even on a Sunday night, we have people
that will tell you
they've been skating here
since they was eight years old.
It's kinda like the mom, the dad,
the teenager, the little brother,
and they all are skating.
It's just a lifestyle
that when you come here,
you get the energy of all
different types of people,
all different types of walk,
but when they come here, they're skaters.
So all those things kind of bundle up
into this building that makes this place,
to me, what the community would miss
if this skating rink wasn't here.
That's why it's been here for
so long, it's still thriving.
You make it about the community,
everything else just
kind of falls into place.
(upbeat music resolves)